this video is brought to you by war
thunder play war thunder for free and
get a premium aircraft tank or ship and
a three-day account upgrade as a bonus
it's available on PC ps4 and Xbox one
more on them in a bit 1066 see the
English throne sits vacant after the
King dies without an heir three
claimants to the title quickly rise and
prepare to do battle over who would wear
the crown at the ends of this turbulent
year invasions would be mounted battles
would be fought and only one man would
be left standing with the prize grasped
in his bloody fists it is a tale that
reads easier as fiction than facts and
in fact it has been the inspiration for
many famous fictional dynastic struggles
including Game of Thrones this is the
story of the victor of this struggle who
conquered a kingdom and changed the fate
of a country and a continent this is the
story of William the Conqueror our story
begins around a thousand sea Viking
raiders have been terrorizing the coasts
of Europe for over 200 years
they took vast tracts of lands by
conquest including the north coast of
France by the English Channel which
eventually became known as the Duchy of
Normandy further advances came on the
British Isles most notably in 1013 when
the King of Denmark conquered England
and
danes ruled the country for 30 years
before being driven out by the native
anglo-saxons in these early feudal times
the central government's controlled by
the king was weak and decentralized the
lands broken up into a series of
earldoms duchies and barren is ruled by
an earl a Duke or a baron these
provincial leaders were in theory
vassals of the king and sworn to him by
an oath of fealty but in practice they
were very much autonomous and struggles
between the king and the provinces and
between the provinces themselves were
common William was born around 1028 C
the illegitimate son of Robert the firs
Duke of Normandy this led to his
original nickname usually used by his
enemies
William the bastard his father seemed to
have little interest in marrying any of
his mistresses which meant that William
was considered the heir to the Duchy
from a very young age in 1035 Roberts
embarks on a pilgrimage to Jerusalem
against the advice of his advisers he
made it to the holy city but fell ill
and died on the return journey leaving
William at age 7 the Duke of Normandy as
was typical when a child inherited a
province or Kingdom there was great
instability in Normandy as the region's
nobles and William's relatives fought
each other for control of the region and
the young Duke a series of William's
guardians were killed including one
Osburn in the Dukes bedchamber while he
slept things came to a head in 10:47
when give burgundy arose in rebellion
against the Duke or government supported
by other Nobles they attempted to
capture Duke William at Vilonia and had
they succeeded he almost certainly would
have been killed but William escaped and
fled south to Paris seeking refuge with
King Henry the first william soon
returned however at the head of an army
and together with the forces of king
henry they defeated the rebels at the
Battle of Val do know that aged eighteen
Duke William was already showing himself
to be a capable soldier and commander
the rebellion of 10:47 was not to be the
end of Normandy's internal strife
William continued to deal with
rebellious Nobles until 1054 at this
point alarmed by the consolidation of
power under William King Henry turned
against his vassal and led an army into
Normandy but he was soundly defeated by
Williams forces and chased out at the
Duchy he tried again in 10:57 and was
defeated again this amnesty continued
until King Henry's death in 1060
[Music]
by 1060 William had largely taken
control of Normandy and put down
opposition to him with the death of King
Henry his seven-year-old son Philip was
named King but he was too young to rule
one of the regions appointed to rule
their kingdom during Philips minority
was William's father-in-law Baldwin v
Count of Flanders so there would be no
trouble from the crown for the time
being
so William therefore turned his focus
towards expansion the Duke acquired some
territory on the continent such as the
County of Maine and fought a campaign in
Brittany but his keenest interest lay to
the north across the channel to England
it was becoming increasingly apparent to
everyone the King Edward the Confessor
would die without producing an heir to
his throne leaving a power vacuum that
various factions would rush in to fill
the most logical internal candidate to
succeed Edward was Harold Godwinson the
Earl of Essex Harold was a leading
member of the Godwin family the most
powerful Nobles in the kingdom he was
also Edwards brother-in-law
however Duke William also felt she had a
legitimate claim to the throne at one
point in 1051 the Godwin's fell out of
favor with King Edward's and were exiled
it's believed that the King reached out
to William at this point and named him
his heir Edward had lived in Normandy
but thirty years after his father was
deposed by the Danes and he was
protected by the Dukes of Normandy so
while this connection made sense however
a year later the Godwin's returned to
England and reconciled with Edward thus
leaving the question of succession
extremely murky some historical sources
tell us that Harold Godwinson travelled
to Normandy around 1064 and met with
Duke William it said that he swore an
oath during that meeting to uphold
William's claim to the throne of England
however the only sources that document
this and Norman and there's no way to
know if this actually took place or if
it was just Norman propaganda
[Music]
King Edward the Confessor died on
January the 5th 1066 what is death bet
he named Harold Godwinson as his heir
Harold acted quickly crowning himself
King the next day and quickly gaining
the support of the English nobility
across the channel in Normandy Duke
William was furious he knew at this
point that the only way to uphold his
claim to the throne would be to take it
by force he vowed to raise an army and
invade England this ambition was hardly
secret and all of Europe watched and
waited throughout the spring and summer
of 1066 as William prepared his invasion
force heralds of course heard of
William's plan and raised an army of his
own to counter the threat of a Norman
invasion he spent most of the summer in
the south of England waiting for Duke
William to make his move however most of
Harold's force was composed of civilian
militia levies that needed to return to
their fields to harvest their crops
since the king was forced to dismiss a
large part of his army on September the
8th and to make matters worse around the
same time Harald learns that another
claimant to the throne had appeared and
just before we get into who that
claimant was and what their men for him
I want to tell you a bit about today's
sponsor war thunder
[Music]
war thunder is a realistic free-to-play
military vehicle combat game it's
available on PC ps4 and Xbox one but you
only need one of those also you don't
need to purchase anything you just
download it and get going in this game
there are over 1500 historically
accurate vehicles all the way from the
1920s to the 1990s they're all carefully
built and super details you can see that
the physics in the game has really been
sweated over and it all looks very very
good sounds incredible too very
cinematic experience and look you can
just jump in for a quick arcade game
which is useful if you don't have a
bunch of time or you could play
realistic and you know do some more
challenging tactical stuff or if you're
hardcore go for simulator and in that
case well you probably like getting your
ass kicked over and over again so join
us on the battlefield for free using the
link below doing that supports this show
and you'll also get a free premium tank
ship or aircraft and three days of
premium time as a bonus just for
registering and let's get back to the
video
a year before the events of 1066 Harold
Godwinson 's brother Tostig had been
stripped of his earldom of Northumbria
and driven into exile infuriated by what
he saw as his brothers betrayal he went
to the king of norway Harald Hardrada
and convinced him to make a claim for
the English throne and invade from the
north of the country
Harold's believed that he had a
legitimate claim to the throne of
England because he was descended from
the line of Vikings that had conquered
and ruled England for thirty years
before Edward the Confessor took over
Harald spent the summer of 1066 making
preparations for his invasion and left
Norway at the end of August with a fleet
of 300 ships and an army of 15,000 men
he landed in England in early September
and met up with toss stick together they
attacked towns and villages throughout
Northumbria and defeated an English army
led by local Lords this prompted the
surrender of the great city of the North
York in the south Harold learns of the
Norwegian invasion and quickly turns
north with as many soldiers as he could
muster he maids the 185 mile trip north
in only four days riding day and night
on September the 25th 1066 the norse
army left their encampments and marched
to Stamford Bridge where they expected
to meet with representatives of the City
of York to receive hostages and supplies
not expecting a fight they left most of
their heavy armor back at the camp and
imagine their surprise then when they
arrived to the camp not to find
townspeople but rather the English Royal
Army just waiting for them
Ilan's Harald Hardrada and Tostig
goodwin's and rode forward to meet their
enemy King Harald approached them alone
he spoke to his brother offering him his
earldom back if he turned against
hot-rodder and sided with him hostage
asked what Harald would offer hot-rodder
for his trouble seven feet of English
grounds for he is taller than other men
Harald replied coolly there could be no
negotiating with rival claimants to the
throne of England and toss stick refused
to switch sides the Battle of Stamford
Bridge
the Norwegians began to retreat across
the bridge a stronger position waiting
for them on the other side as the
English attacked Harold's army was held
up on the bridge by a single Norse
soldier Berserker armed with a
two-handed great axe he killed 40 men
single-handedly before he was finally
killed by an English soldier who floated
under the bridge and stabbed him from
beneath the English rushed across the
bridge meeting the shield wall of the
Norse the battle was furious at some
point Harald Hardrada was mortally
wounded by an arrow and tossed dick
Goodwin soon was slain on the field
the lack of heavy armor on the part of
the Norse made the difference and their
army was just cut to pieces
once the English broke through the Norse
shield wall the battle became a
slaughter by the time it was over ten
thousand were dead Harald allowed the
survivors to return to Norway peacefully
so many had died that only 25 of the
original 300 ships were needed to
transport them back never again would a
Scandinavian army threaten England's the
age of Vikings was over but Herald
didn't have time to celebrate his
victory instead he immediately turns
around and marched south again because
he knew Duke William was coming
[Music]
just three days after the Battle of
Stamford Bridge on September the 28th
the Norman army landed at Penn becae
bridge on the south coast of England
like Harold's William didn't know with
the Norwegian invasion but it worked out
nicely for him because it allowed him to
land unopposed
the Duke moved his forces through the
nearby town of Hastings where he built a
wooden castle there he was content to
wait close to the supply lines via the
sea the herald would have to come to him
Harold heard of William's invasion while
it was marching south but he proceeded
more slowly than he had when responding
to the Norwegian invasion his army was
still recovering from the Battle of
Stamford Bridge and he had to leave a
large part of it in the North
even still he probably moved too quickly
had he waited a few more days he likely
would have had more men at his disposal
to face the Normans as it was Harold's
army encamped at the top of a steep
slope on the night of October the 13th
few miles north of William's fortified
camp at Hastings his efforts to surprise
William failed and the Normans knew that
he was coming the morning of October the
14th Dawn's
unusually bright and warm for October in
England Duke Williams Norman army left
its camp and marched where the English
were William hopes to settle the
question of who should rule England's
with a single decisive battle whoever
won was clearly ordained by God to sit
on the throne is what he believed
[Music]
the English army was almost entirely
composed of infantry with no cavalry and
a few if any archers with that in mind
Harold kept his forces on top of the
hill having his front rank locked
shields to an impenetrable wall that
would fend off the Norman infantry and
cavalry attacks and blunts the effect of
the Norman archers and that's exactly
what happens during the early stages the
battle repeated charges by the Norman
cavalry were repulsed and the Norman
infantry were unable to break through
the shield wall the French archers were
hampered by the steep slope firing
either directly into the shield wall or
over the heads of the English then the
first decisive moment of the day
the left flank of the Norman Army
suddenly broke and ran in a panicked
flight a rumor spread through the ranks
that two Duke William had been killed
and the Normans wanted no part in
continuing the battle without their
leader
even though Harald ordered his army to
remain on the hill some disobeyed and
chased the fleeing Norman's William
though was not dead and he rode through
the ranks of the fleeing soldiers
removing his helmet to show them that he
was still in the fight he managed to
turn them around and attack the pursuing
English outside of the protection of the
shield wall the English took heavy
casualties a lull settled over the
battlefield as the soldiers from both
armies rested their arteries of his left
flank had given William a new idea if he
had portions of his army pretend to
retreat he could provoke the English to
follow and engage them off the hill and
without the shield wall when the battle
recommand Stead's believed he did this
at least twice with moderate success the
english were taking casualties but the
line held the issue was still very much
in doubt as afternoon turned to evening
soon darkness would make further
fighting difficult if not impossible
just as it seems nothing would be
settled that day after all catastrophe
suddenly struck the English King Harald
was hit in the eye with an arrow going
into his brain he fell from his horse
having been killed instantly without
their king the English army was
leaderless and quickly fell apart
the Normans pursued the fleeing English
for a while but was stopped by darkness
it didn't matter though the Battle of
Hastings was over ins
there was only one claimants left to the
English throne
[Music]
despite his victory and the death of
heralds the English still resisted the
Norman invasion for another two months
forcing William to take the city of
london by siege but soon enough it was
over and on Christmas Day 1066 William
was crowned as the King of England it
took another five years for William to
pacify his new realms he dealt with a
series of rebellions by the anglo-saxon
aristocracy William dealt with this by
building a series of castles throughout
England's and giving them to his
supporters in order to keep order over
the lands by the time William died
England was dotted with over 500 castles
the most famous fortress that William
built was the White Tower in London
which eventually became the central keep
of the Tower of London one of Williams
key problems was inability to be in two
places at once when he was in England
there were uprisings in Normandy and
when he was in Normandy there were
rebellions in England William spent most
of his first ten years of his reign
travelling between the two countries
dealing with rebels while also gradually
transforming English life over time most
of the anglo-saxon Nobles had been
replaced by Normans and the ones who
were left began to marry into Norman and
other French families official documents
were written in Latin or French instead
of Old English two works enhance our
modern understanding of this period the
first is the Bayeux Tapestry an
incredible 230 foot long piece of
embroidered cloth commissioned by
Williams brother
odo shortly after the Battle of Hastings
the tapestry depicts the events of 1066
from the Norman side from King Edward's
death to the victory of the Normans at
the Battle of Hastings incredibly this
tapestry has survived intact for over
900 years and can still be seen today in
a dedicated Museum in baya the seconds
work was commissioned by King William in
December 1085 he wanted a complete
record of all the royal holdings in
England's record that came to be called
the Doomsday book this book documented
all the lands of the English realm in
great detail including who had
controlled the lands before the conquest
how much tax revenue the area produced
the number
people who live there even absurdly
specific details such as how many
chickens a particular farmer hads or how
much milk a dairy farm had produced in a
given year this record preserved in the
National Archives in London officers
great insight on the disposition and
administration of England's during the
time of the Norman Conquest
[Music]
in 1087 William returned to Normandy to
deal with his eldest son Robert who was
allied with the King of France in an
attempt to undermine him while engaged
in this campaign
William was injured by the pommel of his
saddle and the wounds grew infected he
was taken to Rouen where his condition
quickly deteriorated William knew he
needed to settle as a fast he left to
Roberts the Duchy of Normandy and his
second son William was given control of
England once it became clear that the
king was going to die his advisors and
courtiers all left him to settle their
own affairs as a result William died
completely alone on September the 9th
1087 aged 59 in the immediate aftermath
of the Kings death his sons Robert
William and Henry all fought each other
row for control of the kingdom Normandy
itself eventually became part of the
kingdom of France and the heritage of
the Vikings was swept away the course of
English history meanwhile was changed
significantly by the events of the
Norman Conquest brought out of the
conquest England's had more closely
identified culturally with Scandinavia
than with continental Europe
afterwards England was brought closer to
France ties which bounded into the
Middle Ages and caused a centuries long
rivalry between the two countries the
story of the Norman Conquest is one of
the most famous in world history it was
a momentous event that shaped the course
of European history for centuries to
come and it bestowed upon William the
first king of England's and Duke of
Normandy a new title one that no one is
likely to forget William the Conqueror
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you're looking for
something to conquer
do check out today's sponsor war thunder
I'm going to link to them below and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]